Hello everyone, this is Frank Defratis.
Welcome to a new season of HoloTalk.
To start this season off, I am in Montreal, Canada, and I am at the holography studio of Holostar.
We're going to be speaking with Bruno Lavigna today, uh who runs the lab here and he's going to be able to tell you a little bit more specifically about what he does here and what they're doing here with HoloStar.
How are you doing, Bruno?
Fine.
This is a great town.
Uh I have to tell you I've I've been doing a lot of traveling lately and uh there are some other towns that you know I like a lot, but uh Montreal just uh it's it's vibrant, there's a lot going on, it has a lot of snap to it, which a lot of cities do.
But the difference with Montreal is the fact that at the same time there's something that's just very laid back about it.
You know, and it's it's uh it's a nice feeling because usually you have one or the other.
You're in a town where it's so boring that you're falling asleep, or a town where it's so hectic that you just feel like your nerves are on edge.
But uh this sort of like has this beautiful balance here and uh I had a chance to uh go up into your mountain area up at Mont Treblanc and was staying in Laval and back down here in Montreal today.
So it's uh good to have you on the show and uh uh why don't you start off by telling us a little bit about uh HoloStar.
Uh I understand it was probably here before you got here, so if you know any early history about it, maybe we could start off with that.
Um well star was uh was a project uh of Eric Bosco at the time.
Uh our first year was in nineteen eighty-eight.
Uh and uh student here uh wanted to build a lab, an holography lab.
So uh everything we got here uh it's because of them.
Uh so we're really grateful of them.
Uh and uh years uh years after years that they've been uh putting some equipment uh in the lab.
So right now we're we're pretty pretty well equipped and um you know uh about his the it about history, it's about that.
Uh Olo Star is first of all an a student lab uh built by student for students so we keep we keep the prices low and everything's that with student uh I won't even attempt the name of the college.
Maybe you could tell everyone the name of the college.
I'm having a hard enough time with the street science.
It's a beautiful language, but I just you know, coming from Philadelphia and the way I talk, you know, just forget about it.
Yeah, it's uh College de Maisonneve.
College de Maisonov.
Well we're gonna have a couple of pictures of the lab uh on the website and there will also be a link to go back to the HoloStar website so that uh when you're listening to Holo Talk, if you call the uh HoloTalk webpage back up you'll see that link there.
Click on the link and it'll take you over to Hollostar.
So instead of just you know sitting there listening to the interview you can actually do a little bit of a a tour.
Um so this is a learning what is it that students are learning here?
Do you approach holography from an artistic standpoint or do you uh approach it from a scientific technical standpoint here at the college?
Uh first of all when we have a student here they have to to uh get their inscription done.
And after that we we do both sides.
Uh we start with uh an artistic approach.
And when we have students that are interested in uh the optical side and uh scientific side, uh you know, we we just help them to to learn more and more.
Now do they get credits, college credits for taking this course?
Nope.
Not at all.
It's just totally elective that they would come in and work with it.
Exactly.
How how is this tied into the college?
Is this a s is this a business?
Is this what is this?
Uh we have a status that is a bit weird because at the same time we are there for the student as an uh workshop, as a workshop, uh like uh other workshop in in the college uh like uh photography and uh music or everything like that.
Uh but at the same time we're uh resource for our uh artists uh in Montreal and in Canada uh 'cause there's not there there's not really much uh labs in Canada.
Uh there used to be uh uh other labs in Montreal but they're gone now.
Uh what ha what happened in Montreal that the holography I was here fifteen years ago the old port for uh images in time and space.
Um it seemed like it was a very active uh holography community here at the time um what happened?
Uh I don't really know but I I I wasn't there at the time so uh I'm still young and uh uh right now uh starting the you're trying to start a holography community up again right yeah uh we we're we're uh trying to build uh a new community here uh so it's uh it's it's what I do with uh Nadia Zugeth here uh which is uh an artist in uh a visual artist and installation and everything.
So we're str we're trying to build back uh the the Montreal commun holography community uh but uh right now the fundings are really low so we're trying to to to find some and we have uh a lot of difficulty but I'm pretty sure and uh in a couple of years uh there'll be uh there'll be some new excitement in holography in Montreal.
Is there anyone that you can think of now who's actively doing holography in the Montreal area at all?
Uh there's still uh maybe you know him uh Georges Dience uh yeah which we do contract here with him uh uh pretty often uh and uh well uh Marie Christian Mathieu uh Philippe Boissman so all very familiar names going back many many years.
Yeah.
Uh so those uh those members are still active st still active but in the last years uh things were pretty low but we're hoping to to build build it back.
Now can uh someone come down here and learn about uh lasers as far as technology and maybe take that learning and go to a community college somewhere to maybe become laser technician or something of that nature.
Uh well I don't really know.
Uh uh almost uh a good part of our student here goes to uh engineering after coming getting here.
Uh I I don't know uh uh a program of uh laser technician or something like that.
Uh when you want to work with optics and lasers and everything that's around it.
Uh right here you have to to have an engineering diploma.
I th I believe uh in the States they have like a twelve month certificate you can get because every hospital that's here in Montreal has lasers inside the hospital and someone has to maintain the lasers.
So you go to a small community college uh get a laser technician certificate and you're the person that the laser companies hire to go around and maintain the equipment.
But that's that's off the side of holography but since you have a laser here it uh it could be something that could be offered anyway.
Yeah.
Yeah sure um why don't you tell us a little about uh projects that you've been working on recently as far as some of the work that you've been doing.
Uh right now we're doing work uh in the Shadogram uh with uh Georges Dience and uh we're still doing contract every summer uh when when the the classes are open for the student uh it's during the semesters and uh we we pretty much uh give the labs to them uh during the semesters.
But in the summer it's time to to get money so we have to do contract and holography and everything.
Uh for for the past years where we were working about like that and uh from years to years uh works the summers and stud with the student uh in the semesters.
Uh we had uh we have a a lot of projects uh like uh the holography kit and uh that we the uh that the holography that kit that we borrow to the to everyone that wants to do holography tell us a little about that that goes out to schools, educators and students as well, right?
There's like four kits that go out that kids can make holograms, right?
Yep.
Uh with this kit we we can uh do uh one beam reflection and uh one beam transmission work.
Uh it's not really big but uh it's uh it's it's really uh nice equipment to start with uh for uh for students that sometimes are twelve years old uh they don't have access to that kind of equipment so they're really grateful uh to to to to be able to do holograms in their basement.
Have you had an opportunity to see work of other artists around the world and and if you have do you feel that artists that have worked in the field of holography in Montreal do they have a specific style that you feel is a little different from what you see in other areas?
Uh I've been traveling a bit but um never got the chance uh because of my study I never got the chance to get out of Montreal really.
Uh so this summer I'm planning to visit uh Oro Center in New York and maybe uh holographic marts with uh John Perry.
Uh well I'm hoping that I can uh try to find to find the fundings to go there.
Uh being a student is not uh not always easy to find the money.
But uh I have a a lot of hope on that side.
Uh for the question about uh Montreal artists, um well I I don't feel that there's anything really different from that they're doing uh uh different from the other parts of the world.
Uh I know that me and Asia uh we're we're starting we hope to start a new feeling about holography.
Uh we have to to do some something different, but yeah, that's that's future.
I've I've been combining holography with some digital photography and photoshop work and uh doing what's I guess considered 2D, 3D type of uh work as well.
So I guess with the computer coming in, do you find yourself uh doing any uh uh computer manipulation of images or are you working more from objects still?
Uh uh we still work f more from objects, but uh we have uh we have linked with uh Montreal company which will uh have uh pretty uh uh integration of digital work uh with holography.
Uh right now I can't I can't talk about it but because I'm under uh NDA.
But uh there's pretty much uh excitement coming uh in the in in next years.
Now how about uh workshops for just the general public?
If uh someone, John Smith or whatever his name would be, would want to come in and do some holograms, can the public take workshops here?
Sure.
Uh we just uh integrate them with the the students.
It's it's it's that easy.
Uh how long is your course run?
Uh it's it's uh twelve uh twelve weeks each semester.
Uh and uh we we do uh a lot of work with the students, uh Shadow gram, uh some uh how do you put it uh in English uh arcanciel uh uh cop cop uh transmission copies.
Okay, yeah H one H two everything like that.
So uh they they pretty much can choose what they want to do and uh we do it with them.
Okay.
Well Bruno is there anything you'd like to add?
Uh w what can you tell us a little I think you did tell us a little about Nadi.
Is there anything you'd like to add?
I know she is out of town, you know today and uh unfortunately we didn't get a chance to get her in on a show but maybe we could get her in over the phone at another time uh to talk about her creative work.
I I imagine you approach it more from the technical aspect uh what about Nadia?
What is uh Uh well Nadia uh began here uh about one year ago uh when she was at uh university and art.
Um uh first of all when when she saw the hologram uh she just flashed yeah uh so uh she came by and uh asked me a lot of uh about holography and at the time I was thinking of leaving here to to finish my study.
And uh right now I'm forming her to to to replace me.
So right now we do for for the f for the next year we do uh a semester each uh of work with the students and I'm hoping uh that in the future she'll get uh sh sh she'll take just run with it.
Yeah.
She she that she'll run the lab.
Uh I'm not t thinking of leaving everything here.
I I still wanna have touch uh I still want to have touch with the students and and the equipment here.
But uh for five years I I left my study uh at university for this.
Yeah for this.
For this exactly I know what you talk about.
So I I need to finish this.
Uh actually need to get on with your life.
Yeah that feeling comes over a lot of us that have been working in holography from time to time.
Why don't you tell us a little about about the equipment up here.
I see you've got the Monster 125 up there.
Maybe you tell us a little bit about that and the other lasers.
Which uh what uh sorry uh the the Monster one uh it's an old laser uh really modified uh to fit our needs uh we we're still opering it uh we st we still do a lot of work with it uh but we're have a lot of work uh uh of op uh on your driver.
For you old timers out there it's a spectrophysics one twenty five which I imagine some of the younger people in holography wouldn't recognize 'cause it uh definitely takes two people to lift that baby up off the floor from what I remember.
Yeah.
Uh well our other laser uh which we don't use anymore because it's too dangerous uh is another spectrophysic uh R gun uh laser uh which is five watts and for the student uh it doesn't really fit our needs uh it's just too dangerous.
Does it still work?
Uh yeah it's uh it still work but uh I hate touching that kind of laser uh but but well do you burn it from time to time just to burn it?
Uh not really.
Uh I I'm well I don't really like it anyway for holography it's not uh really good laser, not good coherence and everything so uh just leave it there for now.
Uh maybe in the future we'll we'll we'll use it to do some really large copies but for now uh we don't we don't want to use that kind of stuff.
Uh and our other laser which is really nice is uh YAG uh 150 milliwatts from Kis Crystal Laser and th this this one i is the one I uh I use the most for now.
But I as I said uh I have a lot of hope in your driver.
Yeah thank you very much.
What what are you planning on using for your workshops and things or taking because you can run it off of batteries.
Yeah.
Uh for now I I I we just want to replace uh the one twenty five yeah the one twenty five with uh uh we would need to to to to put a lot of a lot of work to uh get the one twenty five uh really working well and uh we don't have that kind of times our money so we're we're planning to replace uh replace it with the the diode.
And now if you pop a diode it's thirty five bucks and you're got another one.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So that'll kick the pants off of that one twenty five too.
Mm-hmm.
Uh so right now the I'm really excited to to to try your driver and if if things works uh I'll we're planning to to to get uh a couple of more.
Okay.
Uh let me know so I make sure I have them.
I don't even have one.
I think the one I gave you is maybe one I had.
Yeah, so it's like that uh you know, the shoemaker that has uh holes in his shoes, you know, 'cause he's dude's so busy with everyone else's shoes.
Okay, well Bruno, I want to thank you very much for taking the time to come on the show.
Uh once again this is in Montreal, so uh there's a link on the HoloTalk page.
Click on that, it'll take you over to the HoloStar website.
Uh maybe you want to drop Bruno an email, tell him hi or contact him if you happen to be in the Montreal area and would like to uh learn about holography.
Uh I don't know if you can just stop in, but uh you can contact him and maybe he can give you information about uh workshops uh to come in and make a few holograms of your own.
So Bruno, thank you very much.